In this segment, we introduce
the concept of continuous
random variables and their
characterization in terms of
probability density functions,
or PDFs for short.
Let us first go back to discrete
random variables.
A discrete random variable
takes values
in a discrete set.
There is a total of one unit of
probability assigned to the
possible values.
And the PMF tells us exactly how
much of this probability
is assigned to each value.
So we can think of the bars in
the PMF as point masses with
positive weight that
sit on top of each
possible numerical value.
And we can calculate the
probability that the random
variable falls inside an
interval by adding all the
masses that sit on top
of that interval.
So for example, if we're looking
at the interval from a
to b, the probability of this
interval is equal to the sum
of the probabilities of these
three masses that fall inside
this interval.
On the other hand, a continuous
random variable
will be taking values over
a continuous range--
for example, the real line or an
interval on the real line.
In this case, we still have one
total unit of probability
mass that is assigned to the
possible values of the random
variable, except that this unit
of mass is spread all
over the real line.
But it is not spread in
a uniform manner.
Some parts of the real
line have more
mass per unit length.
Some have less.
How much mass exactly is sitting
on top of each part of
the real line is described by
the probability density
function, this function plotted
here, which we denote
with this notation.
The letter f will always
indicate that we are dealing
with a PDF.
And the subscript will indicate
which random variable
we're talking about.
We use the probability density
function to calculate the
probability that X lies in
a certain interval--
let's say the interval
from a to b.
And we calculate it by finding
the area under the PDF that
sits on top of that interval.
So this area here, the shaded
area, is the probability that
X stakes values in
this interval.
Think of probability
as snow fall.
There is one pound of snow
that has fallen on
top of the real line.
The PDF tells us the height of
the snow accumulated over a
particular point.
We then find the weight of the
overall amount of snow sitting
on top of an interval by
calculating the area under
this curve.
Of course, mathematically, area
under the curve is just
an integral.
So the probability that X takes
values in this interval
is the integral of the PDF over
this particular interval.
What properties should
the PDF have?
By analogy with the discrete
case, a PDF must be
non-negative, because we do
not want to get negative
probabilities.
In the discrete case, the sum
of the PMF entries has to be
equal to 1.
In the continuous case, X is
certain to lie in the interval
between minus infinity
and plus infinity.
So letting a be minus infinity
and b plus infinity, we should
get a probability of 1.
So the total area under the PDF,
when we integrate over
the entire real line, should
be equal to 1.
These two conditions are all
that we need in order to have
a legitimate PDF.
We can now give a formal
definition of what a
continuous random variable is.
A continuous random variable
is a random variable whose
probabilities can be described
by a PDF according to a
formula of this type.
An important point--
the fact that a random variable
takes values on a
continuous set is not enough
to make it what we call a
continuous random variable.
For a continuous random
variable, we're
asking for a bit more--
that it can be described by a
PDF, that a formula of this
type is valid.
Now, once we have the
probabilities of intervals as
given by a PDF, we can use of
additivity to calculate the
probabilities of more
complicated sets.
For example, if you're
interested in the probability
that X lies between 1 and 3 or
that X lies between 4 and 5--
so this is the probability that
X falls in a region that
consists of two disjoint
intervals.
We find the probability of the
union of these two intervals,
by additivity, by adding the
probabilities of the two
intervals, since these intervals
are disjoint.
And then we can use the PDF to
calculate the probabilities of
each one of these intervals
according to this formula.
At this point, you may be
wondering what happened to the
sample space in all
this discussion.
Well, there is still an
underlying sample space
lurking in the background.
And different outcomes in the
sample space result in
different numerical
values for the
random variable of interest.
And when we talk about the
probability that X takes
values between some numbers a
and b, what we really mean is
the probability of those
outcomes for which the
resulting value of
X lies inside
this particular interval.
So that's what probability
means.
On the other hand, once we have
a PDF in our hands, we
can completely forget about the
underlying sample space.
And we can carry out any
calculations we may be
interested in by just working
with the PDF.
So as we move on in this course,
the sample space will
be moved offstage.
There will be less and
less mention of it.
And we will be working just
directly with PDFs or with
PMFs if we are dealing with
discrete random variables.
Let us now build a little bit
on our understanding of what
PDFs really are by looking at
probabilities of small intervals.
Let us look at an interval that
starts at some a and goes
up to some number
a plus delta.
So here, delta is a
positive number.
But we're interested
in the case where
delta is very small.
Let us look at the probability
that X falls in this interval.
The probability that X lies
inside this interval is the
area of this region.
On the other hand, as long as
f does not change too much
over this little interval, which
will be the case if we
have a continuous density f,
then we can approximate the
area we have of this region by
the area of a rectangle where
we keep the height constant.
The area of this rectangle is
equal to the height, which is
the value of the PDF at the
point a, times the base of the
rectangle, which is
equal to delta.
So this gives us an
interpretation of PDFs in
terms of probabilities
of small intervals.
If we take this factor of delta
and send it to the other
side in this approximate
equality, we see that the
value of the PDF can be
interpreted as probability per
unit length.
So PDFs are not probabilities.
They are densities.
Their units are probability
per unit length.
Now, if the probability per unit
length is finite and the
length delta is sent to 0, we
will get 0 probability.
More formally, if we look at
this integral and we let b to
be the same as a, then we obtain
the probability that X
is equal to a.
And on that side, we
get an integral
over a 0 length interval.
And that integral is
going to be 0.
So we obtain that the
probability that X takes a
value equal to a specific,
particular point--
that probability is going
to be equal to 0.
So for a continuous random
variable, any particular point
has 0 probability.
Yet somehow, collectively, the
infinitely many points in an
interval together will have
positive probablility.
Is this a puzzle?
Not really.
That's exactly what happens,
also, with the
ordinary notion of length.
Single points have 0 length, yet
by putting together lots
of points, we can create a set
that has a positive length.
And a final consequence of the
fact that individual points
have 0 length.
Using the additivity axiom,
the probability that our
random variable takes values
inside an interval is equal to
the probability that our random
variable takes a value
of a plus the probability that
our random variable takes a
value of b plus the probability
that our random
variable is strictly
between a and b.
According to our discussion,
this term is equal to 0.
And this term is equal to 0.
And so we conclude that the
probability of a closed
interval is the same as the
probability of an open interval.
When calculating probabilities,
it does not
matter whether we include
the endpoints or not.